A few weeks ago, I told you about the Trump
administration giving a huge contract for
N-95 masks to a company with no employees
whose parent company recently filed for bankruptcy.
And we have another one of these stories we've
now learned about the Trump administration
giving a contract worth anywhere from three
hundred and fifty four million, potentially
up to eight hundred and twelve million dollars
to a tiny Virginia company that has only been
around since January. It's been four months
and everything about this stinks. The company
is called Flow with a P H P H Ello W was created
in January. Brand new company. The CEO is
Dr. Eric Edwards. We'll talk about him in
a minute. He told the Associated Press that
flows mission is to make the American drug
supply chain less reliant on other countries.
That's something Trump's been talking about
a lot. Bringing our supply chains home in
the context of Corona virus. We don't know
much about the company since it's only been
around for four months. But we do know a little
something about their CEO because Dr. Eric
Edwards previously had a company with his
twin brother called Kaleo. They increase the
price of an opioid antidote by 600 percent
over three years at a cost to taxpayers of
one hundred and forty two million dollars.
They tried to get some positive PR by donating
a bunch of doses to first responders.
And then we heard from several law enforcement
agencies that the doses they got from this
company, Kaleo, were sometimes as as little
as four months from expiring. Nice. Nice,
right. They also charged forty five hundred
dollars for their rival to the EpiPen, which
was really more of an insurance scam. It was
the idea was get insurance companies paying
them these outrageous reimbursements for their
competitor to the EpiPen. And of course, what
that leads to is that people's insurance premiums
end up having to go up the idea that, hey,
the insurance company is paying, so we don't
have to worry about it. Well, then everybody's
premiums go up to account for what they expect
to be paying for that and other medications.
Of course, nothing illegal as far as we know.
This is unfortunately, this type of stuff
that's horrifically legal under our system.
So what's the connection? Why is this company
getting such a great deal from the Trump administration?
Well, what we know so far is that Trump's
wacky economic adviser, Peter Navarro, admitted
he bonded with a board member of this company
flow over.
Get this skepticism about China. Seems like
China skepticism can be very, very profitable
for this for for people associated with this
administration. So what exactly is this company
going to be doing for their three hundred
and fifty four million dollars? They aim to
manufacture some of the raw ingredients for
drugs in the United States. That would be
needed to treat Corona virus patients. We
don't exactly know what that means. The contract
is initially for three hundred and fifty four
million dollars over four years. It could
be extended to a 10 year deal for eight hundred
and twelve million dollars. This would be
one of the largest amounts of money ever awarded
to a company in this type of arrangement.
Now, you may not be surprised that the Flow
website has a lot of the same sort of America
first style rhetoric and language that Trump
often bandy is about. So in a week we might
hear about some further connection to the
Trump family. Wouldn't be surprising. It'll
barely get attention. It'll be another one
of these crony moves that Donald Trump promised
to stop. This is a classic cash grab and you
see this a lot and more corrupt countries
or countries that are more corrupt in this
particular way. The U.S. is corrupted in sort
of different ways.
Often you have a crisis and all sorts of brand
new companies will be setup. Very few employees.
Very few questions about whether they really
do anything and they get these massive lucrative
contracts. This specific case with this company
flow, it may or may not be an out and out
scam. Most likely the company is going to
do something. But there could be shell companies
involved. These are often techniques to hide
foreign interests or other nefarious interests.
You can use these to funnel money around and
in a lot of different ways, it's the type
of stuff Trump loves. And in the end, it's
our tax money. It's our tax money during times
of crisis that gets funneled to people that
are making so much money while 25 percent
of the workforce has lost their jobs. This
is what sixty three million people voted for,
either knowingly or unknowingly. I was reminded
when I was researching this story about the
Whitefish fiasco during the Puerto Rican hurricane
recovery. Although to call it a recovery is
probably probably a bit of an exaggeration.
There was this company, Whitefish Energy,
based in Montana to full time and. Loyce,
they concocted an online presence with 100
online positive reviews. They did it all within
72 hours of getting a three hundred million
dollar contract from the Trump administration.
The Trump Interior Secretary at the time,
Ryan Zonkey, happened to be from the same
town as this company. People associated with
the company happened to be big investors,
big investors. Talk about a Freudian slip.
Donors to Donald Trump. It was a total swamp
job.
And eventually Puerto Rico canceled the contract.
And now we are indeed seeing much of the same
around Corona virus. A lot of money being
made with Corona virus, that's for sure.